yeah
then I shall bow
in home
alone
don't reach out
the final farewell to Country icon
Loretta Lynn took place on Sunday at the
Grand Ole Opry House with thousands of
friends family and fans to celebrate her
life during a memorable evening to my
friends thank you for giving me such a
great laugh I have never taken it or you
for granted I'm so grateful to Loretta
Lynn for being an example for all
songwriters everywhere but most
specifically female songwriters getting
to say things that might make people
uncomfortable she was so ahead of her
time I am honored
to have been in your presence Loretta I
am grateful to have
have so many memories with you I am
proud to be a woman in country music I
am proud to be a mom I am proud
to have had the privilege Glory
to have had the privilege
of following
for so many of us of following you down
the musical path you blaze for all of us
I just want to say thank you Loretta
thank you I love that country him yes I
do
what you say I was made just to fit your
plans but there's a bar in your Chapel
fit your hand
cause if you're looking at me
and you're looking at Country we know
that Loretta's resting in peace she's
left a wonderful Legacy she left a
wonderful memory she was the best friend
anybody could ever have you've been
making a rag around town
but the man I love when he picks up
trash he puts it in the garbage can
she's an angel